the top issue is right now a sense of
frustration that they're not sure
whether or not they're making a
difference and so you know what was top
on the minds of the folks that we're
talking we were talking to when we
started discussing philanthropy was how
can I have more confidence than actually
making a change and if I'm going to
continue doing this I need to know
better that my dollars are actually
improving someone's life and that's not
only findings from our study but other
studies where people have said have
asked the question what would make you
give more and it was better information
on cost and better information on impact
I don't even think in the top five or
ten it was more of a tax benefit
what we do know is that there's a lot of
there's a lot of talk surrounding a kind
of generational shift in philanthropy a
set of philanthropists who want and
expect more involvement in whatever
philanthropic activity they are engaged
in so you know the idea is that if
that's where they're starting if there's
this desire to be more than a more than
just writing the checks then I think
what the sector needs to do is figure
out how can you leverage those good
intentions and frankly a lot of talent
that could be servicing the mission of
the organization and and make sure that
you know that talent that energy doesn't
go too distracting folks from the
mission of the organization or that
organizations don't somehow get beholden
to the whims of a philanthropist that
things that this is their pet project